[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je suis ravi de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro d' europe et
donnons pas depuis le parlement européen
comme à l'accoutumée danse coronavirus
oblige nous traversons une crise
sanitaire 1 depuis des semaines inédite
face à laquelle douze états européens
ont décrété l'état d'urgence
limitation de la circulation encadrement
de gauche du parlement lutte contre les
infections ou encore des réflexions
droit de manifester beaucoup d'états se
sont dotés d'un cadre d'exception autant
de mutations aux libertés individuelles
et collectives prise au nom de la lutte
contre la pandémie
mais était ce nécessaire et surtout
est-ce efficace tout l'état d'urgence
sera utile pour moi georges caroli vous
êtes ambassades de leurs revenus en
france depuis cinq ans bienvenue à vous
j'ai au jour de plaisir d'accueillir
bonjour emmanuel mois l eurodéputé
français vous siéger au sein du groupe
de la gauche unitaire bonjour bonjour
nous accompagne tout au long de cette
émission deux autres invités deux
citoyennes européennes vont vous écouter
et intervenir pour nous faire part de
leurs remarques et leurs réflexions
depuis madrid
myriam anciaux et ça a annoncé l je vous
dis à tout à l'heure mais dame
ma première question va s'adresser à
vous emmanuel maurel au vu de la
situation sanitaire est nécessaire
vraiment décrété nepad urgent de prendre
des mesures exceptionnelles envoyés sur
nos libertés nécessaire peut-être mais
en tout cas ce qui est vrai c'est que le
confinement obligatoire en temps de paix
à quelque chose de complètement inédit
parce que vous priver au nom de
l'efficacité au nom de la lutte contre
la pandémie les citoyens d'un droit
absolument fondamental qui est celui
d'aller et venir et voulait priver aussi
de tous les droits
at non le droit se réunir leur droit à
se rassembler
droit à manifester le droit de pratiquer
son culte
tout ça c'est des libertés auxquelles
les citoyens ont dû renoncer pour des
motifs sanitaires et ce qui est très
important de mon avis c'est quand même
d'avoir une vigilance particulière par
rapport à toutes les lois du d'état
d'urgence vous y faisiez allusion à
l'instant qui ont été votées dans
certains pays pour que la réponse des
pouvoirs publics soient proportionnées à
la crise est conforme à l'état de droit
sainghin reviendra sans doute un peu
plus tard georges caroli hongrie vous
avez les tensions en main est-ce qu'on
peut tirer un premier bilan est ce que
cela a été efficace et cela a permis à
votre pays de jubilé le virus
je tiens à préciser que angry ya eu
environ 500 décès pour le moment pour à
peu près population doit absolument le
nombre des décès en hongrie est très
inférieur à ce qu'il est en proportion
dans d'autres pays
il est vraisemblablement due pour partie
aux mesures qui ont été prises il est
peut-être due aussi à d'autres facteurs
de santé ou médicaux que on révélera un
jour je pense qu'il est beaucoup trop
tôt aujourd'hui de savoir pour quelle
raison ce virus se développe de manière
différente du pays à pays
mais ce qui est certain c'est que la
hongrie a pris très rapidement peut être
même avant beaucoup d'autres pays
un certain nombre de mesures qui force
est de le constater ce sont ou ont trait
se sont montrés efficaces
certains pays un an au sein de l'union
européenne n'ont pas décrété l'état
d'urgence et des pays n'ont pas non pas
des moindres on parle notamment de
l'allemagne qui a pourtant eu connu peu
de décès par rapport en tout cas sa
population parce qu'on est au tour de de
8000 morts
donc on peut faire sans état d'urgence
monsieur à carreaux it vous avez le
l'état d'urgence perse personnellement
je suis confiné comme tout le monde à
paris depuis depuis depuis plus de blois
je n'ai jamais considéré que ce
confinement était une atteinte
intolérable à la liberté démocratique
d'aller et venir
vous savez la vie n'est pas un long
fleuve tranquille de nos de nos désirs
satisfait il y a des contrariétés tout
le temps et m'entendre paix et lorsque
l'événement aussi imprévue est aussi
grave que le corps on admire us de
tomber dessus
je trouve tout à fait normal c'est tout
à fait normal que des mesures soient
prises
j'espère justement nous allons voir un
petit peu plus insensés les mesures
adoptées en tête de l'état d'urgence
fabien drecker dresse pour un comparatif
entre aurait comme la france la hongrie
vit actuellement sous un régime
d'exception en france l'état d'urgence
sanitaire voté le 23 mars a été
prolongée jusqu'au 10 juillet la hongrie
a quant à elle décrété l'état d'urgence
sanitaire le 11 mars avant qu'il ne soit
prolongée
deux semaines plus tard par le parlement
hongrois et ce pour une durée illimitée
une restriction du rôle du parlement
sans date limite qui a fait l'objet de
vives critiques au niveau européen la
commission européenne s'inquiète
notamment des dérogations au droit du
travail permise par l'état d'urgence en
hongrie ainsi que de possibles atteintes
à la protection des données personnelles
autre source d'inquiétude le crime de
diffusion de fausses nouvelles sur le
virus ou sur l'action du gouvernement
passible de cinq ans de prison pour les
organisations de défense de la presse
la mesure ouvre la porte à la censure
récemment deux opposants ont été
interpellés par la police après avoir
critiqué le gouvernement sur facebook
enfin des coupes budgétaires visant
notamment les partis politiques et les
communes officiellement pour faire des
économies ont suscité l'indignation de
l'opposition hongroise en france non
plus le gouvernement ne s'est pas privé
de légiférer par ordonnances l'exécutif
en a émis plus de 60 depuis le début de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
elles concernent par exemple la
modification de la procédure pénale
le droit du travail ou le report des
élections municipales consulter à quatre
reprises depuis le début de la crise
le parlement a toutefois joué son rôle
sur le traçage des malades ou le recours
à la main
mise en quarantaine les parlementaires
ont amendé la loi pour protéger les
libertés
mardi 26 mai le gouvernement hongrois a
déposé une motion au parlement pour
mettre fin aux pouvoirs spéciaux
accordés à viktor orban
la mesure doit encore être voté le fit
days parti du premier ministre dispose
d'une majorité des deux tiers à
l'assemblée hongrois
[Musique]
la levée de l'état d'urgence devrait
intervenir hongrie 1 le 20 juin
george karl dit comment interpréter
cette volte face est ce que cela acte la
fin de la pandémie ou bien leur vie en
quelque sorte aider aux pressions
internationales et européennes
je crois que l'interprétation est très
simple votre le sujet a dit que la
hongrie avait que les parlements encore
avaient prolongé l'état d'urgence pour
une durée indéterminée
ce qui se passe en ce moment montrent
que c'est totalement faux la date de
validité de l'état d'urgence était la
même que celle de la durée du danger qui
l'a motivé alors à partir du moment où
le gouvernement hongrois jusque dans son
tennis et danger est passé
eh bien nous mettons fin à l'état
d'urgence emmanuel maurel nombreux
danseurs et confiante transfusé victor
banon utiliser la crise sanitaire pour
s'octroyer les pleins pouvoirs mais
finalement la hongrie va sans doute en
sortir de l'état d'urgence avant la
france et avant d'autres elle est il
vraiment s'inquiéter le vous savez il ya
une résolution du parlement européen en
avril 2020 qui faisait état de ses
préoccupations dans la plupart des pays
européens mais notamment en hongrie et
en pologne parce qu'ils estimaient que
les mesures qui ont été prises par les
parlements n'étaient pas proportionnées
aux exigences de la situation et
n'étaient pas nécessairement conforme à
l'état de droit mais en ce qui concerne
par exemple la hongrie ça n'a rien
d'exceptionnel ça fait des années
maintenant que les autorités européennes
mais aussi le conseil de l'europe mais
aussi un certain nombre de hedge et
dénonce des dérives avérée de monsieur
norman et de son parti alors anglais
c'est particulièrement le cas avec la
loi sur les faits que nous entre
guillemets qui pouvait justifier cinq
ans d'emprisonnement
mais dans deux pays à commencer par le
mien je le reconnais il ya des
tentations de la part du pouvoir
exécutif de l'inerte de limiter la
liberté d'expression au nom de la lutte
contre cet ennemi invisible que le virus
est bien vraiment il faut sortir de
cette rhétorique faut être très vigilant
très vigilant et je moi je vous posiez
la question
on éviterait légitimement est-ce qu'il
faut nécessairement passer par une
législation d'exception et par la mise
en place d'un état d'urgence moi je ne
suis pas sûr regardé en france par
exemple on est en état d'urgence depuis
2004 on l'entend georges tin relis je
voudrais que l'on revienne sur une des
mesures évoquées par emmanuel maurel les
arrestations notamment pour fausses
nouvelles ou fake nous dans le cadre de
l'état d'urgence et qui ont été vivement
dénoncée est perçue comme un moyen de
museler la presse cette mesure en
particulier ce qu'il était vraiment
justifié vous savez tous pays à la côte
pénale dans une période comme celle là
il est tout à fait légitime de veiller à
la diffusion de fausses nouvelles
surtout de fausses nouvelles alarmistes
là je vous signale au passage que la
définition des fausses nouvelles adoptée
par le gouvernement hongrois est
exactement la même que celle de l'union
européenne et je signale aussi qu'à
partir d'aujourd'hui d'hier à partir du
moment où décidant de lever l'état
d'urgence tout cela donc aussi lorsqu'il
concernant neuf ans c'est long et 80
cette procédure lancée cette garde à vue
c'est pas le cas dans tous les pays
européens mais les gardes à vue dont
vous parlez ont été levées certes deux
personnes ont été arrêtées par la police
hongroise
elles ont été relâchés après quelques
heures ce sont des événements qui se
produisent dans tous les pays est ce que
vous pouvez me dire qu'en france la
police endroits la police française n'a
pas fait preuve d'un certain excès de
zèle aussi dans certains cas vis-à-vis
de certains gilet jaune s'est quant à
elle est la vice-présidente de la
commission européenne met à jour va qui
a réaffirmé sa préoccupation il ya
quelques jours concernant l'état
d'urgence ombres et de la sittelle
souhaite que la hongrie reviennent mais
ces mots crack ou incontestable emmanuel
maurel elle est contestable la
démocratie hongroise on l'a on glisse ça
date pas de l'état d'urgence et de la
duc o vie de 19 depuis maintenant
plusieurs années vous avez la commission
le conseil de l'europe le parlement
européen un certain nombre d ong
d'institutions européennes spécialisé
dans les droits de l'homme qui alerte
sur des projets de loi qui ont été
voulus par la majorité
/ mais monsieur morel bon vous évoquiez
des faits qui datent d'il ya dix ans il
faut savoir terminer une grève est pas
loin
où est le genre de débat enfin cher
monsieur c'est bon c'est difficile de
débattre à distance mais enfin je
voudrais pas vous rappeler que au sein
même de la droite européenne
c'est-à-dire le ppe dans lequel siège le
fid est le parti de monsieur or ban vous
avez été mis au ban de ce parti
précisément parce qu'il y avait un
certain nombre d'infractions à l'état de
droit dans votre pays
je me permets de vous couper et je
voudrais quand même qu'on regarde il y à
une étude un enfant de recherche
allemand qui a comparé les différents
états d'urgence parce que je revenais un
petit peu à la thématique l'état
d'urgence au sol l'union européenne
ainsi pelé voilà et qui compare les
mesures restrictives de liberté campe et
moi ainsi s'est classé comme portant des
attentes sévère aux libertés c'est le
cas de la france
c'est le cas de la hongrie mais c'est
également le cas de l'italie et de
l'espagne
emmanuel maurel voilà ma question y at
il aussi un problème démocratique dans
notre pays cc c'est je suis difficile de
vous répondre en un mot à cette question
particulière mais ce que je crois en
tout cas c'est qu'il ya tout il ya une
dérive lente depuis plusieurs années
kieren progressivement sur les libertés
publiques y compris en france et vous
avez des gens je vous renvoie à l
ouvrage de l'avocat sur aux cayes qu'il
a écrit un un petit texte chez gallimard
sur la dégradation des libertés
publiques en france dans tous les
domaines ce soit liberté d'expression
françois sureau voilà exactement liberté
d'expression droit de manifester usage
disproportionné de la force des forces
de répression envers des manifestants en
france
tout ça c'est une réalité est donc
aujourd'hui ce qu'il convient de faire
un sursaut au niveau français comme au
niveau européen pour que nous restions
une terre attaché aux droits de l'homme
aux libertés fondamentales
vous parlez de sept critères elle n'a
pas attendrir les divergences déjà
ancienne l'europe démocratique peut-elle
continuer à avancer un mal gré
le fossé qui se creuse c'est une analyse
signée annick appel de la part de
l'actionnaire
alors dans cette crise nos libertés à
tous ont été bridée chaque état membre a
mis en place des mesures fortes pour
endiguer l'épidémie forcément il ya eu
des différences dans la réponse apportée
par les uns et les autres lors on
pourrait dire que cela répondait à des
besoins spécifiques et ponctuels et
pourtant dans une large mesure ces
différences étaient là bien avant le
printemps
et c'est crise n'a fait que les
accentuer ça fait des années que viktor
orban même son travail de sape pour
tenter d'imposer son modèle de la
démocratie libérale
il n'a pas attendu le coran navires us
ça fait longtemps que la démocratie est
en crise dans cette partie de l'europe
et ceux coronavirus et bien il agit
comme un amplificateur de cette crise il
amplifie la bataille idéologique entre
deux modèles démocratiques
c'est une solide épreuve pour l'europe
sans doute la plus grave de son
existence lors la question c'est comment
l'union va-t-elle résister il est sans
doute trop tôt pour le savoir
mais certains signes ne trompent pas il
suffit de regarder comment la commission
européenne a réagi face à la décision de
viktor orban de s'accorder les pleins
pouvoirs de façon illimitée elle a réagi
timidement beaucoup trop timidement à
l'instar d'ailleurs de ce qu'elle a fait
ses dernières années qu'en fin mars
viktor orban a obtenu le feu vert de son
parlement
la commission européenne a fait part de
son inquiétude profonde
elle a rappelé que les mesures prises
par les gouvernements les gouvernements
devaient rester proportionnés et de
nature temporaire mais dans un premier
temps elle l'a fait sans même nommé la
hongrie ensuite malgré la demande
pressante du parlement européen elle n'a
pas jugé opportun de prendre des
sanctions vis-à-vis de budapest
donc non seulement cette crise a
accentué les divergences mais elle a
confirmé l'impuissance de la commission
à ramener la hongrie sur le chemin de la
démocratie
george karl yannick capelle parle dans
sa chronique de bataille idéologique
entre deux modèles démocratiques
quelle valeur l'année souhaite défendre
en europe
écoutez je suis très étonné sinon
scandalisé parce que cette personne a
déclaré dire que la hongrie n'est pas un
pays démocratique est un scandale majeur
disent que l'union européenne n'a pas
réagi suffisamment vivement est une
opinion politique qui ne fait que
démontrer la frustration de ceux qui
voudraient que la hongrie soit clouée au
pilori de l'europe du matin jusqu'au
soir ce qui est absolument inadmissible
l'arrondi je vous le rappelle en prenant
les mesures de son état d'urgence ne
nous a pas prises pour maintenir une
dignité on est en face aux mets de
reprendre ce qui aujourd'hui n'existe
plus et ce qui n'a jamais existé
connaît on est en plein dans le procès
d'intention
là on oublie effectué laquelle d'autres
quelle manière la plus nette défendre en
europe qui dépendent étroitement par le
vos valeurs
moi je récuse absolument je ne comprends
pas d'ailleurs pour quelle raison on
nous reproche de ne pas respecter les
valeurs de l'europe étant donné que la
hongrie comme des 26 autres pays membres
font partie des valeurs européennes et
lounge estimant que les valeurs ce que
nous défendons sont parfaitement sont de
même nature et de même niveau que celle
défendue par tous les pays maintenant
chacun à sa façon des braves un certain
nombre de choses nous avons sur les
grandes questions de société une vision
différente de celle de l'europe
occidentale
je ne vois pas pour quelle raison il
faudrait que nous soyons du matin
jusqu'au soir
cloué au pilori pour avoir une vision
différente de la famille et du mariage
de la vie de la relation ans prénommé
une femme tout ça ce sont des questions
tu peux faire débat qui font d'ailleurs
débat mais qui n'ont aucune raison
d'être stigmatisés et ostracisés
emmanuel maurel est ce qu'il ya des
valeurs des fonds notamment desquels on
peut transiger
l'union européenne ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'on ne peut pas transiger avec eux les
textes fondamentaux qui je parle je
pense notamment la charte des droits
fondamentaux qui régissent le permettre
c'est l'article 2 emmanuel maurel
l'union est fondée sur les valeurs de
respect de la dignité humaine de liberté
de démocratie d'égalité de l'état de
droit ainsi que de respect des droits de
l'homme y compris les droits des
personnes appartenant à des minorités
est ce qu'on peut transiger avec
certaines de ses valeurs ses
fondamentaux
bah non je ne crois pas sinon l'union
européenne n'est plus le projet
politique d'unification d'un continent
autour de principes forts ça n'est juste
qu'un grand marché dans ce cas là il ya
un certain nombre d'européens qui
trouvant sera moins intéressant mais je
reviens sur la question vous avez posé à
l'instant monsieur l'ambassadeur
il ya un projet politique de la hongrie
de monsieur urban
d'ailleurs c'est confirmé regardez hier
monsieur urban a salué un homme
politique européen
un seul c'est monsieur salvini et il ya
une convergence de vues entre les deux
c'est le nationalisme proche de
l'extrême droite qui prône une certaine
vision en effet de la vie en société et
de la construction européenne c'est pas
la mienne je lacombe a fermement mais
quand même
j'ajoute un point qui ne devrait pas
faire débat vous dites on a le droit
d'avoir chacun notre conception de la
famille du rôle des des hommes et des
femmes dans la société
certes mais quand même dans la charte
des droits fondamentaux à laquelle vous
êtes obligés de souscrire quand vous
adhérer à l'union européenne
il ya des choses très précis sur le
droit des minorités sexuelles le droit à
l'éducation sexuelle pour les pour les
femmes l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes le droit d'être d'avoir la
sexualité de son choix va ça pour le
coup c'est des choses qui ne devrait pas
être remise en cause par les
gouvernements or c'est le cas dans
certains gouvernements notamment
d'europe de l'est
et ça ça pose un problème parce que on
sort du cadre qui est définie par la
charte des droits fondamentaux
4 et pouvez-vous vous savez le l'article
2 du traité - européenne et non un
certain nombre de principes
notamment celui de l'étude de l'état de
droit que de la penderie bien évidemment
respect et quand vous dites monsieur
morel que l'on ne peut pas transiger sur
ces principes
je suis bien évidemment d'accord mais
encore faut-il savoir le sens qu'on
donne aux mots transiger ce sont des
grands principes
ce ne sont pas des règles normatives qui
font l'objet d'un compte rendu de la
part des états c'est considérer ces
fameuses valeurs qui sont énoncés dans
l'article 80 dans l'article 2 peuvent
elles-mêmes être interprété dans un
certain cadre bien évidemment s'en
sortir d'un cadre mais elles ne sont pas
figées elles ne sont pas
d'interprétation uniforme par tout le
monde c'est tout ce que nous souhaitons
elles revêtent un caractère obligatoire
il faut quand même évident le dire
l'article 2 qui est du même avis en
enlever des territoires évidemment
qu'elle revête un caractère obligatoire
mais encore une fois puisque c'est une
état de droit qui est capable de me dire
ce qu'est l'état de droit personne
l'état de droit est une option extrême
tabac c'est quand même un cabanon messi
mais parce que l'état de droit on peut
vous voyez ça c'est bien le problème
mais non l'état des droits est un
principe dans le ciel vous mettez un
certain nombre de règles normatives et
plus dans ces règles là que l'on examine
une par une pour savoir si dans tel ou
tel éclat la démocratie l'égalité des
sexes et tout ce que vous voulez est
correctement respecté en ce qui concerne
la hongrie je ne vois pas pourquoi je ne
vois pas où l'état de droit avec un
grand a et 1,2 md serait menacée là il
ya une vraie différence d'interprétation
parce que monsieur l'ambassadeur vient
de dire oui mais moi je ne sais pas
définir l'état de droit si justement
l'état doit il ya des définitions
juridiques très précises j'ai enseigné
le droit constitutionnel pendant dix ans
je peux vous dire que le premier cours
sur l'état de droit
on avait des définitions s'est pas
seulement des principes contrairement à
ce que vous dites
les principes après l'ondé traduction
concrète dans les textes de loi dans les
garanties qui sont proposés
aussi les moyens et tout ça mais je suis
désolé mais ça ne fait pas roger winock
une autre s'il n'y avait pas des
divergences d'interprétation où serions
nous nous avons quand même encore le
droit de débattre sur ce qu'est l'état
de droit face à wil avait aidé enseigné
le droit constitutionnel pendant dix ans
moi je les ai étudié en puisant sans
rechigner
mais je sais je sais très bien je sais
très bien que les les lignes au tec sont
pleines de livres qui essaye de définir
ce qu'est l'état de droit moi je veux
bien tout ce qu'on voit bien on voit
bien là que en tout cas il ya un débat
et qu'il ya des divergences cette
cotation messieurs depuis le début de ce
débat deux citoyennes vous écoutent
attentivement je vais vous les présentez
myriam en chauffe d'être manager en
ressources humaines vous êtes française
mais vous habitez à madrid 1-2 puis 2018
et puis il ya également saâne film vous
êtes belge vous avait 36 ans vous êtes
consultante et que vous habitez
bruxelles myriam si vous aviez une chose
voilà que vous retenez de ce débat de
cet échange autour
voilà d'état droit des libertés quel
serait-il moi ce que je retiens quand
même tous ces débats un finalement dans
une situation de crise tristane banon
qui touche à la sueur mais finalement
des populations finalement tout le focus
va sur des intérêts politiques ou bien
sur des orientations politiques et sur
une limitation des droits qui final on
voit pas bien là la relation finalement
avec la protection de la survie entre
guillemets toute la focalisation bave
sur les attitudes individuelles les
droits individuels nos libertés
individuelles
il ya quand même un manque énorme
finalement d'information et de et de
prise de dynamique sur comment est-ce
qu'on peut solutionner ça en actions de
forme coordonnées de forme coopérative
parce que finalement on entend parler
d'opposition
on entend parler de divergences
d'opinion on entend parler de l'unité à
l'extrême les droits individuels puisque
je pense que dans l'europe il ya eu des
thèmes mesures qui ont été prises
l'espagne comme vous l'avait dit il ya
des mesures qui ont été très très très
intrusive dans ma vie privée mais
quelque part avec une espèce de message
relayé que chaque individu n'a pas bhl a
de prendre la mesure de la gravité de la
situation et donc il vaut mieux
finalement le restreindre au maximum et
le pister justement va passer à la
dernière partie de l'émission où toutes
les deux un vous allez nous raconter
comment vous avez concrètement vécu ces
restrictions liberté en espagne en
belgique
mais avant je vais remercier emmanuel
maurel 1 et georges tarhoni d'avoir
participé à ce débat
merci à tous les deux leurs émissions
directes madrid où vous habitez myriam
un confinement très stricte depuis des
semaines encore aujourd'hui vous n'êtes
autorisé à sortir que très peu de chez
vous c'est ça il a été décidé de passer
en face une de 3 0 une deux trois quatre
qui finalement redonne un certain nombre
de libertés fondamentales la situation
en espagne c'est que pour le moment
bahia certaines régions qui sont par
exemple en face d'eux au point sur le
point de passer en phase iii c'est à
dire en retour à coubertin mais
vaillants commence à avoir des
mouvements contestation 1 contre ces
mesures restrictives oui mais en réalité
elles ont été très très forte et surtout
il n'y a pas eu forcément beaucoup de
compréhension sur pourquoi on pouvait
passer ou pas de phrase
il ya beaucoup de débat politique autour
de ça et d'une manière générale avait
quand même une grosse contestation qui
se lève dans dans le pays et des
oppositions finalement entre entre
idéologies politiques encore une fois
entre ceux qui considèrent que les
mesures ont été excessives auxquelles
ont duré trop longtemps on a fermé les
parcs comme vous voyez les enfants
peuvent pas sortir
personne ne peut aller courir at a pu
aller courir avec vous personnellement
est ce que vous les avez compris ces
restrictions de liberté les premiers les
premiers temps évidemment quand on est
face à une crise on comprend que le
temps de s'organiser il faut quand même
y mettre du sien en tout le monde le
comprend et c'est logique il faut un
petit temps d'adaptation maintenant le
prolongement de cette façon avec
vraiment une intrusion au niveau
personnel par exemple les membres d'une
même famille ne pouvait pas voyager dans
une voiture on veut pas changer de
région on peut pas sortir a prise de x
mètres de chez soi on pouvait pas aller
courir à l'uni ce moment au début un
camp mais je me disais tiens c'est quand
même un niveau de détails dans ce qui
est interdit de faire qui est assez
élevé phase 1 finalement un délai très
très long pour avoir un début de
de compréhension de ce qui peut être
fait pour retourner à la vie normale
l'entente mais il ya beaucoup d' entrave
je voudrais également temps de retard à
al fin depuis bruxelles il ya eu moins
de restriction en belgique clairement
mais vous dites vous avez des contrats
par émission que ces traits culturels
expliquez nous effectivement il ya peu
on a gardé toujours la possibilité de se
balader seul ou avec un ami
donc c'est quelque chose qui étaient
invérifiables étant donné qu'ils avaient
pas de système d'attestation et donc il
y avait vraiment une collaboration qui a
été demandé aux citoyens et on était je
trouve plus dans une démarche d'adhésion
de co-création avec ce qui se passait
plutôt que d'obéissance unilatérale à
des règles venu d'angers pu constater
que c'était culturel j'avais peur qu'on
entend dans l'aspect très français est
un pardon pour répondu à votre question
effectivement parce que je m'inquiétais
du coup de l'état un peu psychologique
de mes amis est basé en france et en
particulier à paris et finalement il
acceptait il comprenait en fait il
fallait en passer par là en france tout
faire respecter les consignes et en
belgique ça n'a pas du tout été le cas
en fait les on a pu constater une
adhésion effective et à ce quasi
immédiate de l'entièreté de la grande
majorité de la population dès le départ
en fait il n'a pas du tout fallu qu'on
passe par des menaces de d'amande qui
pleuvent et c'est vrai que moi
personnellement j'ai j'appréhendais un
peu que l'attestation soit mis en place
en belgique et aussi marion deux films
avaient choqué c'était que j'ai en juin
faisant du camp en france après quatre
fois vous étiez prise dans une certain
laps de temps sans protestation on
parlait même de peines de prison non
mais il y avait surtout les amendes en
tout cas on voit bien là entre l'espagne
la france et la belgique
les divergences d'approchés on va
s'arrêter là merci à toutes les pour vos
témoignages c'est la fin de cette
émission où pouvait la voir et la revoir
sur notre site publicsenat.fr mais
également sur l'antenne de la rtbf
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles 0 peine
[Musique]